[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to add dead of night
this game combines 3d environment with
some kind of full motion video
i'm not exactly sure review sightings i
haven't seen anything yet
game stats nothing to show i've done
nothing i'm a useless lump
receiver instructions on supernatural
communication a word of caution
editor ignore all the things that i just
read i'm gonna make a summary
ghost either big energy like big dick
ghost energy
or small dick ghost energy the ghosts no
matter what energy
they are the souls of the dead and you
gotta respect so
always keep that mind you always respect
what am i doing
whatever okay let's go
oh oh
oh that's cool oh that's kind of cool i
like that
that means am i jimmy
who's this
[Applause]
oh
hannah where are you you all went off
and left me behind
where are you now what's this number
we've all booked into a hotel
how far away are you i don't know i'll
have to call when i get there
well it doesn't matter just go to bed
hannah
hmm make sure
make sure you don't go into the murder
hole
not the hotel with the murderer in it
oh boy
this is always a good start to
everything
this is cool i love this styling i love
it
i love the mixture it's dope i presume
why oh don't be alarmed uh your friends
booked you in
uh let me just check
ah yes uh room 101 it's all been paid
for so you don't have to worry about
anything
you're very nice friends very nice
and there's uh quite a few of you i
see as well very nice nice to see so
many
fresh young faces
therefore it is uh you're here for the
music
festival in town i presume yeah we were
supposed to be camping there tonight
but there's hardly weather for that is
that no
yes whatever you want will you be
staying for breakfast
i don't think so we'll probably just get
going that's fine
and uh if you don't mind me asking maya
would you be interested in uh
the entertainment tonight tonight uh
starts around midnight usually it's
it's me doing it actually comedy
i do this comedy character called a hugo
punch he's sort of this comedic
sociopath says things that you're not
supposed to say
and that sort of thing sounds very
popular with students
oh okay i don't think so we're all just
going to bed i think
are you sure i can't twist your arm on
this
it's okay i'd rather just go to bed
sorry
hi fine fine which way are the rooms
um just take the lift uh you're on the
first floor
okay thanks take the lift to the first
floor oh and and then drop your key off
in the box
uh if you will maya please tomorrow
best show in town and notetakers
who needs proper entertainment when
you've got
youtube and
[Music]
okay don't start this again
i don't want to hear it okay not tonight
they need to be taught a lesson
[Music]
shut up just shut up
you always do this they're paying
customers
they haven't done anything to you
just leave them alone bad eggs need
cracking whack them hard and crack the
shell
kick them down the stairs to hell
you know what you need to do jimmy show
them who's boss
that's the way to do it
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it i really do i actually love
this this is great
it's fantastic
um
[Music]
hmm
i love the mixture i love the mixture
the mixture is so cool
hmm
[Music]
i mean i guess my friends are you know
in the hotel so
oh here we go
this eview hotel has a dark past
[Music]
its ghosts have a story to tell
use the ghost and spirit receiver to
talk to them
they'll tell you jimmy's secrets i think
i know
jimmy's secrets i think jimmy's secret's
his big old murder face
i think hugo punch is uh is a little uh
you know murdery you know a little
chilly
stabby type kind of person at all costs
i miss what the last
sentence hey jimmy i love it
i'm all about this this is the device
you found select this to switch it on
should i oh weird man i am
i'm quaking you need to find a compass
and a scrying mirror
okay i'm actually going to be right back
so hopefully
nothing horrible happens while i'm away
i actually have to go real quick but i
will be back
[Music]
boo i'm back hello hello um
so what what am i doing again select
this device dude
okay uh conduct spirits voices if you're
near enough to them
if you haven't seen it go to the menu
and watch the tutorial video before you
can
[Music]
tutorial video watch tutorial watch full
tutorial
nah i'm okay i i know that this is
probably a bad idea
try to make contact with his spirit
start conversations by asking
introductory questions
if there's no reply there's no spirits
around when you meet spirits you can ask
them questions pair their replies to
make connections when you're alone you
can review spirit's replies
here this loud noise means there's a
spirit in a high energy state
a loud noise okay is anyone there is
anyone there
is anyone there is anyone there is
someone there
seems like no one's there all right okay
interesting oh i
love this style i mean it's very
reminiscent of
old point-and-click adventure games but
i do
genuinely think that there's still like
good reason you need to find a compass
and a scrying mirror there's still good
reason to have
stuff like this it's super fun it's just
it's fun is anyone here
is someone there okay i'm guessing loud
noise will
will it'll prompt me for a noise when
there's actually something around
like i'm guessing it's gonna be pretty
obvious
oh my goodness well i don't want to
wander around this place
can i go out can i leave
i'm sure that would have been an obvious
choice hey
ooh the bachelors
damn i guess not
i guess not what's cool about this is it
like it's it's moving in real time so
it's got actual
it's got actual feel to it anyone in
here who's that
hello no okay cool
that's fine you know i didn't want to
talk to you anyway i'm only uh
here to witness all my friends being
picked off one by one
oh this is weird
i don't like it i don't like it i guess
i'll try the elevator
what if there's someone in it oh god how
am i gonna
i don't know lg telephone hello can i
i'll just go from the top i'm gonna
start from the top and then i'm gonna go
work my way down
that seems like a logical strategy and
by logical strategy i mean absolutely
not logical at all hello oh boy
hi anybody there
hi i'm sure the screaming in the
distance is totally fine
i mean maybe that's screaming it could
also be just
wind whistling through a door or a
window
could be that now it sounds more like
wind
sounds a lot like wind oh
god oh god damn all of this
i'll go towards the sound of the wind i
guess i think it's here no
no hello well i didn't meet oh my oh
seems safe safe as can be
hey what's up
what's up hiding the wardrobe well
that's good to know
search here
i guess not hang on i found some mirrors
okay good open notes broken mirrors make
contact with the spirit to ask
about this okay is there anyone here
there's someone there
okay is me talking gonna let
hugo know where i am or jimmy
or whoever
i love it and i hate it i hate
everything about this
oh i don't like it okay is
someone there oh wow look at that
there's a lot of detail in this game
okay i do lock the door behind me so
that's awfully good
to know where is the whistling is it
just from that window
oh no but what if someone was behind me
oh god i hate it i
hate it look at that painting zoom in on
that dude
oh i know what i need to find shut up
i'm gonna get there
wait where do i look i look spy no
looking i just go in
oh no oh dark room
oh no oh no too dark ahead you're right
something tells me the bathroom would
not be the best hiding spot
was that me squeaking that was me
squeaking what am i an idiot
yes so there was an option to look
through the keyhole i just didn't know
how to get it
okay there was nothing else down this
way right okay cool
are the music be swallowing at this
juncture was that someone else or was
that me
i don't know what anything is what's
with the balloons
who dared you to get balloons here
who's having a party what is this ladies
room
i am a lady nope
good you know honestly good because
bathrooms in horror games
never turn out good for nobody
god why would i look at that wall oh no
not the not the gentleman's room either
i don't know what i'm looking for i
don't know what i'm doing
look through keyhole hello
nothing easy perfect great good stuff
let's go baby all right
that's oh no no that's probably
probably nothing search here away
point towards nearby spirits
how how do i do what do i do where where
compass is someone there is someone
there
search here oh that seems useful
i like the sound of that did i not get
it did i not take that
i guess like the mirrors it wouldn't be
good to carry there with me
okay coil of water and they contacted
know about this i need a scrying mirror
i would never exit a door that way
when i would fear my demise okay points
towards nearby well it sure looks like
what
hello jimmy
okay it's pointing towards the wall but
that's unhelpful
doesn't seem to be oriented properly
usually there's kind of a stationary
spot
okay oh a ring in its box
good stuff oh hello
there's a lot of detail
store room i can go buy something
from jimmy's shop wow
i think we could buy some mercy buy a
way to get out try
keys open two try keys open the
inventory face the door and select a key
okay doors can be locked or unlocked
with the right key
that's good to know so i need to find
the store room
whatever the store storeroom is probably
on the first floor
i noted a wedding ring anybody here is
anyone there
is anyone there sure feels like i'm
finding a lot of somethings and a whole
lot of nothings at the same time
okay you know you know maybe this is
just a big like lesson ghosts aren't
real
so trying to check with some weird
edison electronic receiver from like
probably isn't like i'm gonna feel like
an idiot
at the end of this there never were no
ghosts
never existed never existed
i know what i need let's see if this is
the storeroom
store
that was this
oh no why would i come here
i guess if i was in there i should lock
it and then he couldn't get in because
apparently the master key don't work for
that
apparently
so i can't take the stairs unless i
probably get like a stairway
key well this saying there's a ghost
somewhere over here
what do you mean there's a ghost that
was over here what
here compass how do you work
where are you pointing where are you
where are you
pointing you are unhelpful okay i think
this floor is clear
so i'm gonna go down
what if he's in the levator what if he's
in the levator
levator would be suggestive of a place
to really get me there's only one
he could really get me in the levator
i don't like the womp
more balloons
yeah turn around yeah don't look around
you not important
what's with all the loons whose party
who had a party and why
why party stop there's cameras here
there's cameras everywhere
oh there's a bird outside does that mean
he gets to see me
he's not allowed to do that is this also
a storeroom
can i it's also a storeroom
oh i'm gonna lock it i'm i'm locking it
i'm locking this
you're locked great good that's actually
the best thing i've ever heard
what is this no go that way
feel the room there's blankets books and
boxes
the three basic bees of everyone's a
life blights
blall paper blows
okay so my compass is pointy pointing
this
maybe down here why would you point it
oh that's at that
oh that closet ain't what is this
hell hallway all the way of hell
i have to pee let me piss
you will never let me be screw you
i'm gonna need you anyway didn't need
any of this
it's also dark okay so i need to find
some kind of a light
okay so floor one that's where i saw
my friend get murdered so i'm gonna go
there cause you know if i saw someone
chloroforming my friend i would sprint
down that hallway and drop kick
that [ __ ] in the face faster than
they knocked out my friend with
chloroform
because that that was really a prime
opportunity real prime opportunity
anna here hannah mary what mary mary who
was hannah someone was hannah
i don't know oh no
the bathroom's open [ __ ] [ __ ] got
the men's room good
no i can't go in there it's against
policy
oh hi okay so this is also a storeroom
try the try what do you mean try the
door why would i try the door
oh no
i don't like it i like it i don't like
it
i don't like it i don't like it none oh
that's a fun symbol hey look at the art
beautiful this is great moving in
hi oh is that i see i see a flashlight
right there hello is anyone there
anyone there no there's no one here
okay so it's fine but i do see a
flashlight there and also the big symbol
is weird but whatever
because no one wants to talk to me okay
this is all good this is good i know
what i need
oh masks great
it's wonderful well you're pointing
there
hello i can't see
dick dick and diddly
ah as i assumed dick exactly
hello is someone there
i would not be speaking this loudly in a
perfectly dark room you know screw that
uh
nothing here weird uh absolutely uh as i
suspected diddly also dick
so you know there's that hello
uh okay so it's bright and shiny and no
one's there
great i'm guessing this dude also has a
master key which probably isn't great
for my health
nothing okay wow first floor is a bust
first floor i should have checked the
mirror a lot of the
window and people the i should have
peeped
oh no this way
oh this oh no that's where i saw the oh
that's where my friend was all
yeah dry door is locked
located nothingness either someone's
looking at me
screw that screw that every way screw
that what is that
what do i do what do i do about that is
that good bad
what is it what does that mean
i don't like it what are you is it my
friend
oh god go ahead and don't go in oh god i
think if i it doesn't look like is that
jimmy
is that what a jimmy looks like i don't
know is that what i'm supposed to find i
don't
think so what happens do i lose her save
save current game god please save me
it can't be good it can't be how many
people are screaming at me not to go in
i have to hello oh
and there i've learned because i'm brave
i'm a big brave boy i hate that
mannequin
i'm a big brave boy
no one no one can tell me
how brave i is what's going what's going
on back there
that's fine that's fine i knew it
i knew it i knew it
hello search here oh chef hat
i'll try hot wow finally
i can go play cooking simulator oh
[ __ ]
[Applause]
i already know about that that's fine i
oh no
i oh either by the door in the rooms on
the or on the ground floor of the
kitchen what
he's a mirror to see clues about where
to go or which items to use next
it will also help you locate lost keys
compasses in the ghost box
okay cool good this is good stuff
what did i do about the mirror what what
do i what am i supposed
i'm a little confused how do i do the
scribe mirror
it's grayed out i think that means i
can't use it here or now or
ever because i'm dumb and i didn't read
the one sentence in that
mirror i'm looking
[Music]
hi child
ma'am
[Music]
this vision is uh this vision is
something else
this vision's uh i didn't like that
i don't like that so i gotta go to
l'oreal
so am i should i be worried about all
those other ones where
uh uh jimmy jimmy hugo
huge jimmy was uh looming with his uh
bat should i be worried about that
should i
no we'll look through the keyhole
nice hole okay i'm going in i'm coming
in we're fine
no no it's all grayed out
okay i will search oh
weapon time jimmy baby always weapon
time
well okay take it damn it
whoa jimmy your
art wow
this is really something jnjh okay
fringe comedy award to jimmy hall
all right good all right it's crying
[Music]
mirror
kind of funny you know kind of funny
okay that
child it's child or old lady
but either way
[Music]
i gotta go down to the lagoon
there's a lagoon around here all right
well time to go to the fro hey man
time to go to the old lagoon i guess
this one i went in this one
yeah i went in that one yeah it's i
already got that i know that
i did those because i'm thorough but i
didn't go to this side did i
no this side was dark no it wasn't oh
god
no did i go no i didn't
jimmy oh
jamie
what am i seeing well i don't see a
jimmy so oh it's my room
oh it's my room that's right hey
my room oh my backpack you'd think that
i would have something
a little weird that was in my
room little strange don't you think
little odd
that's my key i'm an idiot and i left
that no never mind stairs floor one
i'm not sure what terpentine is but
whether i'm cooking meth or someone put
these in here
it wasn't mine officer the bottle of
turpentine and the syringe of diazepam
it was placed there i'm leaving now
i'm leaving i'm going away now
you can't stop me no down that hallway
see
yes oh scary
scary okay it's fine don't you move
[ __ ] don't you move [ __ ]
amnesia mr statue got a new job
okay that's dark it's it's dork in there
it's dork
okay this one it's uh not dork okay not
dork
not dork i go in hello
one of these days jimmy's just gonna be
in here or maybe not i don't know i'm
getting too confident
hey wow 102
deadlock keyed at 102 huh
i'm in 102.
oh so i can uh safety in 102.
so super safety comes at those i bet
that means like the closet ain't too
good of a place to hide probably
hello okay nobody
nobody nobody
nobody nobody nobody
hello why is very quick very quick
hello okay
hello jimmy's sleeping in bed
the gymster oh
yay okay so 102 and 104
i'm in 104. i've got safeties in 102 and
104.
i think that's how that works if it's
not how it works
i'm not gonna have the reaction time to
do it anyway so don't matter
it don't matter none it don't even
matter
don't even matter it don't matter zero
i don't know why me moving thinks me
that i can see more me but i'm
i'm dumb so everyone's just weird stains
hello i already have a compass okay so
more than one compass that i could have
found
oh good oh a storeroom i already have
that but i guess it's redundancies just
in case you didn't get it
so you wouldn't have to wait too long
okay i didn't look through the keyhole
okay i'm done here you stay there you
[ __ ]
hello jimmy hello jimmy hello
god who are you go away hello
hi who's behind me what is down here
what no there's more
i don't like that this is the storeroom
maybe
storeroom store room nice
excellent actually the best no don't
look at there i already know
fully confident 100 i will lock it
because i'm paranoid as hell okay
blankets wells boxes a
leather duster a bleather bluster
blankets it's a whole lot of nothing why
would i why
why nothing it's nothing must just be
like exclusively a hidey hole except for
don't
yeah there we go except for that one
that has like the desk on it that seems
special
but i don't know why yet hello
i'm coming in getting a little too
brazen about this but you know
brazen is my middle name after all hello
wow okay 106. deadlock great i think
that's good
now you know on the spectrum of good and
not good i'm a hundred percent certain
that is not good
that is 100 not good yeah you know not
good
actually now that i've confirmed it no
i've confirmed
okay i thought i heard something
did i hear something oh no oh
how big is this goddamn hotel this first
floor is infinitely larger
oh i hate it oh no it's so
beefy what am i looking at
it's fine it's fine
give me your secrets give them to me
yes 112 i've got a lot of deadlocks
uh which is good i'm guessing and i
already have that
oh wow bottle of whiskey and other
spirits spirits
spirits you say safe current game
story's zero percent complete
i'm trying what do you mean zero percent
complete
just because i've been wandering around
looking in every room maybe i only
needed to find this stuff and i didn't
actually need to go through meticulously
every room and find
everything and there's actually nothing
that's going to happen until you go down
to the lurch
the lagoon but you know um it's
fun kind of dark no not fun
shut up oh okay
i'm just gonna start barging into these
rooms let's screw it
okay let's go let's go let's go what do
we got what do we got nothing let me out
of here
get me out of here jimmy be damned
nothing going forward
i don't like open doors but handcuffs
okay
totally fine
hello
nothing i don't know why
why is he coming on edge nothing's
happened
nothing will happen probably how big
how big how big oh
my
[Music]
there's a storeroom what is this okay
it's a storeroom
is there anything ever going to be in a
storeroom that i need to be aware of
guessing i don't need to lock in unless
someone's actively like coming for me
okay
it's nothing okay storm is just hidey
hole
you
ooh a child's purse
is it weird to me that a child would
have a purse is that especially like
that i don't know this game
seems to be british so things are
slightly different
also i have not found a single ghost but
i think that's because i have to go down
to the basement
nothing oh what's behind me
how big oh that oh
i somehow went in a loop-a-d-loop oh i
went in a loop-a-d-loop
okay so there was a loop-de-loop but now
i'm confused because
i don't i am unsure of where i've been
and no
i where i've been and where i'm going i
know there was an offshoot down this way
what's down here nothing hello that's
definitely a storeroom i'm not even
gonna worry about that i'm gonna go
here look at you have i looked at you
i can't look at you too dork
you look at you
okay i might have been in you i don't
know
i have not suitcases these fines are
excellent
you know what if it was a complete
misunderstanding i'm just going through
everybody's belongings
marking down evidence looking for ghosts
meanwhile i'm the paranoid [ __ ] that
is going through everyone's underwear
then again underwear is explicit proof
of ghost existence
it's just a fact that's how it is
ah keep it take it i don't care if it's
ornamental take it
take it take it take it take it take it
take it take the thing
take it hello anybody mind if i take
this sword
jimmy's you know jimmy's bat really
won't do much against my sword
i don't care if it's decorative if you
hit someone with an unsharp sword it
still
hurts cause you know it's a big piece of
metal
also it can be shoved up the ass of
anyone that's trying to murder me
okay oh
but apparently i can't go in because the
deadlock
because the deadlock right right right
the deadlock
oh my god i hate that what are you doing
oh you're up
it's my friends it's so obvious now
it's my friends okay time to go to lurch
or lower ground if you're i don't know
unoriginal
and stupid so apparently something
important was not
i don't like the thumps
[Music]
oh
oh loud can i hide in those i don't know
i don't know that's just a storeroom i
got a key for that but i don't need it
oh who's in here hello
oh what is the big machine
why uh
hello
why am i down here so there's something
down here there's definitely a ghost
says there's a ghost this in way
this in way no
not this in way this in way in here is
there a ghost in here
no yes it's spinning
hello hello
there's someone there okay well i guess
i'm wrong
now it's pointing backwards what is
wrong with you
maybe it's in the storeroom here sean
key's a
store try the try
why would that make it why did i need to
try it first
oh
now it's spinning wait here hello
is anyone there
call out to wait why would i do that i
feel like i'm close to the truth but
just not quite getting it
let me go back to the first floor i feel
like i'm close
just not quite let me go to uh
i see where was the first floor stairs
that's interesting
i do oh oh my [ __ ] god
god damn you
why do i go back down yeah i know that
the girl in the basement is a bit of a
problem
a bit of a problem girl in the basement
okay
make contact with the spirit to ask
about this what do i go back down
so it wasn't an old lady it was a
child okay where the stair stairs stairs
there stairs stairs stairs so i do have
the key for this
thanks
so go down
hello oh god
oh god so now i have stair access
between one and two that's good
but what about going down from here
where does this lead to
oh yeah
damn
is anyone there
so i gotta go back down to the basement
of course i gotta go back down oh cars
i saw the ghost why wouldn't i go meet
the ghost i'm an idiot guys i'm so dumb
i make connections ten times later than
it should be
but don't worry about it shut up i've
got it here i go talk to a ghost
i'm going back down because yeah of
course as soon as i saw the why didn't i
go back down of course it makes so much
sense did i even say that i should go i
feel like i considered it and then i
didn't do it
is someone there
hello what's your name hello
amy bell
okay amy all right ask spirits about
things you've seen
ah you'll see their reply when selecting
the item
okay i saw a girl in the basement crying
who was she i'm guessing that's your
[Music]
is yours
by jimmy versus mine
interesting uh do you have a drinking
problem
[Music]
well now i could have had it but i don't
i saw some suitcases in the chest who
did they belong to
yes i don't know how good are you then
okay why is there a blood-stained cloth
in one of the drawers
it could have been nice
oh i found a bottle of turpentine in the
lighter
i don't know what were they for what is
that i didn't know what they were
until jimmy showed me
oh what does that mean where did the
bottle of diazepam come from
i don't know okay i found some trophies
who won them
why vega who drew those violent pictures
the boy the the boy jimmy the boy or a
different boy
what good are you what was the coil of
wire used for
used to carry it around why would he do
that
how did those mirrors get broken oh
jimmy was it jimmy
okay thank you later nerd
oh my god what is the deal save
current game a return zero percent
complete of the story how much do you
want from me
have i completed like 0.001 percent of
the story and this is like a
this is a marathon 500 hour game let's
go back to the ground floor because i
know i haven't
explored everything i was skewed over
the ground floor so you know i
didn't i don't like those i don't like
the kabooms
i don't like the baboons just don't like
them
i think they're weird okay so are you
pointing down this way
god i hope not okay so you're pointing
where are you pointing i hate this
compass
all right let's go in the weird hallway
oh
arcade oh sweet time crisis three
dude awesome
dude this place is dope anybody here
is someone there all right fine
shut up i'm gonna be here for a while i
think jimmy can kill me
let's just keep playing god maybe this
place ain't so bad
after all do not like this hallway
try the door yeah let's go for it
there's a storm
yeah of course it is all right cool
beans
[Music]
sweet beans these beans are sweet
the sweetest beans okay
uh
[Music]
was i not done with asking her what the
deal oh
the purse
oh
brain blast right i need to go make
connections i'm an evidence
collector apparently i'm collectivizing
evidence makes so much sense i bet
that when i make these connections i bet
when i make these connections
it's she's gonna answer something about
me so there's someone there
hello hello is it amy
is it is it amy
well that's good okay good good okay so
hair and then hair
match two replies you think connect to
work out the spirit story
parasiting replies with items replies
for faster progress
when you said jimmy stole things from
you is that connected with what you said
about the purse
is it is it connected yes
that bastard gotta hit him with a bat
what's happening
well there's a monkey i don't like
baboons what is that
[Music]
so am i done here who's that
oh you're gone ah okay
so i know where that thing said next
that was the arcade that i was just at
we're gonna play some video games
four
someone having a good time over here oh
god oh yeah
that's fine interesting is someone
having a good time over here
is it amy is it amy
[Music]
okay i saw you shouting to jimmy to give
your toy back
why did he take it because he thought it
was funny
[Music]
that bastard that rat bastard
you ruin it with the sword what you said
about jimmy stealing your toy
does that have anything to do with what
you said about the sword
well that's not very helpful is it what
you said about jimmy stealing your toy
does that have something to do with the
blood-stained cloth
[Music]
wait a while oh did i do too much oh
what
well whatever all right um
so do i just wait let me go look at the
scrying mirror and see what the scrying
mirror is all about
water water water once the bringer of
life and now the bringer of toy death
interesting no floor recommendation but
something about
water i always knew that the connection
would bring us back to
water water where did i see water there
was a bathroom on the first floor
could have been in the water in the
bathroom in the first floor it's perfect
it's too perfect
what is someone there i haven't asked
about this yet about what
oh i have things you're asking me about
oh am i dumb
okay hello is anyone there
hello amy
okay what about these broke mirrors
oh wait no amy didn't have an answer god
damn it damn it
oh wait whoa
what you said about jimmy stealing your
toy does that have something to do with
what you said about the turpentine and
lighting did he burn it
[Music]
one
all right okay i gotta go to first floor
bathroom i see now we're in it
now we're in it to win it i'm winning it
and i'm in it
nothing will stop my genius from
marching forward unless jimmy stops me
from letting my genius march forward
which is still entirely a possibility i
haven't seen
much of jimmy is this where the bathroom
is all about
is anyone there no no no
so i just got to go find there's
something on the first floor i just got
to go find it
do i trust that or not i'm gonna try i'm
trusting it oh yeah here we go
trust big trust energy
we've got a winner oh we got a winner we
got a winner baby
oh we got a winner
[Music]
what do you mean do i have the key for
109 oh god
oh god oh no oh no oh no oh god no
no what do you mean shut up go away
what am i doing about that
hey okay i forgot that you weren't you
didn't you don't sound too threatening
so i guess it's not as scary
so i'm okay come at me [ __ ] i got kung
fu out of my ass
and this kung fu at my ass is gonna go
right up your ass and then you're gonna
have
con you're gonna be dead is what's gonna
happen
[Music]
oh yeah just try it try me
you won't you can't you shout
this is the perfect room to be in
because i got a sword in here and i
could
oh my god you [ __ ]
why would you do that to me why would
you do that
to me is it amy
yes i may be
jimmy gonna get me i saw you holding a
toy
on fire what happened
okay floor two huh great
okay so we still got a problem
we got we got a jimmy sized problem
let's use the scrying mirror real quick
armor okay armor i know armor
and then there's this dude
[Music]
some mirror says some mirror it doesn't
sound like he's close
so i'm gonna go and if i find
one of the rooms
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god what no no oh my god
oh my god it's a dead end
why would i do let me just check my keys
real quick what keys do i have
oh 112 okay even numbers
2 4 6 12. okay
i don't remember which way to go get out
of here
no no get going faster
faster is where you go
okay i'm gonna turn around i'm looking
okay i looked
i have no idea how to get back to the
elevator but i think i'm close
yes i'm free
shut up i was never here
almost too easy jimmy's an
idiot don't even know where i am
stupid fool
[Music]
you know this is quite a game
i actually am really enjoying this it's
quite good
i do like this there's a lot of cool
stuff happening here
i'm gonna do more episodes of this i've
only i've been doing this for an hour
and a half i'm only seven percent into
it well
it's cool i like the style i like the
pacing it's slow burn but
man it keeps you on edge the whole time
i love that that's cool
i'm sure that as i get into it like i'll
understand the game more obviously i
went through the whole
goddamn hotel first jumping at shadows
and there was nothing there but now
i'm actually in the thick of it so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know you think down in the comments
below
this is cool i really like it it's very
fun
let me know what you think though uh and
uh as always
i will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]